la comisión europea ha autorizado un
nuevo contrato con la farmacéutica
pfiezer para tener 300 millones de dosis
de su nueva vacuna aún en fase
experimental pero que según el análisis
preliminar tiene una eficacia superior
al 90 por ciento no es el único contrato
que tiene la comisión europea ya tiene
acuerdos con hasta 5 farmacéuticas entre
ellas astrazéneca o también sanofi el
objetivo es que todo el mundo pueda
tener acceso a esta vacuna y una vez sea
aprobada pueda repartirse de forma
simultánea entre los países bien
miembros en función de su población
además la comisión europea hoy ha
propuesto tener muchas más competencias
en materia de sanidad actualmente ahora
sólo es competencia de los estados
miembros pero la comisión europea quiere
reforzar a las agencias europeas como la
del medicamento y también la de control
de enfermedades para que puedan tener
mucho más poder y margen de maniobra
ante futuras pandemias además propone la
creación de una nueva agencia para hacer
frente a emergencias sanitarias y poder
actuar con muchísima más rapidez
bruselas cree que la falta de
coordinación
los países miembros provoca muchas más
vulnerabilidades y por ello es necesario
que la unión europea tenga mucho más
poder o de lo contrario se puede volver
a repetir el caos vivido a principios de
la pandemia